um die körperliche leistungsfähigkeit
von soldatinnen und soldaten des
jägerbataillons 12 in der oster richtig
kaserne sicherzustellen gibt es seit
jeher eine intensive zusammenarbeit
zwischen der truppe und dem harris
sportzentrum davon überzeugt sich
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
am 12 mai 2020 vor ort in amstetten bin
beeindruckt von der einsatzfähigkeit von
der ausbildung die die soldatinnen und
soldaten durchlaufen egal ob sie
kadersoldaten sind oder jetzt eben
erstmalig auch in vorbereitung für die
milizsoldaten sehr beeindruckend die
insbesondere auch die sportmedizinische
betreuung die insbesondere auch hier
sehr notwendig ist bei der sogenannten
im rechten regale die körperliche
leistungsfähigkeit für diese daten ist
ganz ganz entscheidend für die
auftragserfüllung und nachdem das
österreichische bundesheer über ein
hehres sportzentrum mit den
sportwissenschaftlichen kompetenzen
verfügt ist natürlich diese
zusammenarbeit ganz entscheidend für
beide seiten für die entwicklung der
truppe im bereich der körperlichen
leistungsfähigkeit und für das hsz im
sinne des zusammenarbeiten oder das
zuführen von informationen an die truppe
getestet wird im soldaten parcours und
dem 3,2 kilometern maschen es ist
eigentlich ganz einfach die leute laufen
und es wird einfach die zeit genommen
bei diesen so garten parcours der aus
vier teil stationen besteht aus bewegen
im gelände heben tragen von lasten sinn
von lasten und ablegen von lasten und
teilweise um die belastungen analysieren
zu können wird das ganze natürlich mit
der pulsuhr mitgeprägt damit man sieht
wie die beanspruchung bei einzelnen
soldaten selbst während einer gefechts
vorführung wird die körperliche fitness
gemessen also wissen ist dass die leute
in der karl albert ausbildung zu sehen
schon wirklich gut im bereich da sind
wirklich sehr gut trainiert sehen und in
die richtung gehen muss uns erhoffen
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
zeigt sich ob der leistungen der
soldatinnen und soldaten beeindruckt es
ist beeindruckend und die
österreicherinnen und österreicher
können sich vor allem sicher fühlen die
soldaten gehen bestens vorbereitet in
die einsätze immer dann wenn sie
angefordert werden von
sicherheitsbehörden von den
gesundheitsbehörden hier von amstetten
ausgehen insbesondere dann an die
verschiedenen grenzübergängen in
niederösterreich system bestens dafür
vorbereitet und
auch trainiert